lui c'est tristan colombet à 23 ans ce
jeune chef d'entreprise amuse plus de
250000 personnes chaque jour grâce à
internet son site breezy point com un
site sans obligation d'achat qui peut
rapporter gros à celui qui s'y
connectent comment le plus souvent en
grattant donc là en l'occurrence il faut
gratter le panier et trouver des
carottes donc là un premier ticket perdu
à l'âge et gagne donc une carotte j'ai
gagné un centime d'euros un centime par
6 10 centimes par là les gains
s'accumulent dans un coffre-fort virtuel
et permettent d'obtenir des cadeaux qui
vont du simple stylo à l'écran plasma il
n'y a pas d'assurance de gagner cela dit
je veux dire par rapport au nombre total
de joueurs il ya quand même des moyennes
et je veux dire la grande majorité des
gens qui viennent entre 20 et 30 jours
de suite peuvent repartir assez
facilement avec un petit cadeau tristan
lui a tiré le gros lot le chiffre
d'affaires de son entreprise installée à
aubière dépassera cette année les 5
millions d'euros une somme rondelette
générés par les options et jeu payant du
site un site régulièrement renouvelés
par 45 salariés pour ne pas lasser les
internautes mais l'intéressé c'est quand
même d'avoir des jeux assez simple mais
aussi qui plaisent aux joueurs donc on
attache énormément d'importance au
retour qu'on peut avoir encore au stade
de la conception voici le prochain jeu
qui sera mise en ligne surprise' son nom
le défi de diabolo un jeu qui met en
scène à des quatre personnages
récurrents du site un site qui reçoit
700 mille nouvelles visites chaque mois
on a eu la chance de tomber sur mon
peut-être une bonne période l'as vu que
la société a été créée juste après
l'éclatement de la bulle internet
c'était le moment où tout le monde se
remette un petit comment un petit peu en
cause et où tout le monde partait sur de
bonnes bases l'expansion de la petite
entreprise n'est pas terminée le site
est en cours de traduction en anglais
italien espagnol et allemand enfin dans
quelques mois la construction de
nouveaux locaux doit débuter deux mille
mètres carrés à la part-dieu pouvant
accueillir 150 personnes
[Musique]